لذا فإن بوتين اليوم يصل إلى وجهة نظرك حول إعلان
الشخصيات هنا عن جنرالته
الرابعة في أقل من عام للإشراف
على الحرب في أوكرانيا على وجه التحديد والتي من
الواضح أنها ليست سجلاً جيدًا ولكن
الرجل الذي يتولى الآن مسؤولية جيراسيموف
كان في الواقع الشخص الذي يدير
الجيش الروسي  على مدار العقد الماضي ، كان
الجيش الذي رأينا جميعًا
أدائه في ساحة المعركة ،
فما رأيك في
أن يُعهد إلى جيراسيموف الآن فجأة بهذه
القيادة العليا واستبدال الجنود ،
إنها خطوة غريبة آرون ، نعم أنت تعلم
أنها ستكون مكافئة  بأخذ
رئيس هيئة الأركان المشتركة
ميلي في الولايات المتحدة
ووضعه في الخطوط الأمامية لحملة عملياتية
كان في طليعتها
كما قلت للتو ، الجيش الروسي
ليس فقط جيشًا ، إنه سلاح
مشاة سلاح الجو البحري.  هذه الأشياء ،
لذلك قد يكون ذلك بمثابة تنبؤ لمحاولة
هجمات مستقبلية في مناطق مختلفة من
العمليات مع القوات البحرية والجوية
ولكني أعتقد  إنها مرة أخرى ، إنها
حركة مدفوعة بالشخصية ، إنها في الواقع
تخفيض رتبة لجاراسيموف شخص
كان في موسكو على مدار السنوات العشر الماضية ،
وهو أيضًا خفض رتبة سافويكين الذي حصل
بالفعل على الأمر
في المقدمة للروس ولم يفعل ذلك.  لا أفعل
كل ذلك بشكل جيد ، لذا فهو مزعج بالنسبة
لي ومربك بالنسبة لي لماذا فعل السيد بوتين
ذلك بخلاف احتمال
إلقاء اللوم على جاراسيموف الذي يعتبر من
الداخل في الكرملين